it's hard with the kids behind you doing
that they're laughing yep Hank it's
Sunday it's news day in the news today
is that I went to the Netherlands and I
want to tell you about it so Hank I've
just gotten home from a week of touring
Holland with two other American authors
jordan sun and blake and steve Kluger
and man it was fun god I love the
Netherlands I love it too public
transportation the amazingly nice
teachers lounges and its public schools
it's daring architecture and of course
it's amazing cafes with their brilliant
bitter balls Peter :
oh man Hank I wish you had taste Oh
vision so you could know what happens
when they mix meat and hope and then fry
it Oh Hank and also on this trip to the
Netherlands I discovered a new amazing
Dutch delicacy pokken shocking by the
way I pretty much made up the name
Hawkins Walken it's a Dutch delicacy
it's white bread butter and chocolate
sprinkles
I'm gonna swap some chairs to do beer
balls I mean Hank is the poet hath wrote
ooh baby do you know what that's worth
ooh
heaven is a place on earth and as if all
that weren't enough on Thursday night
the city of Amsterdam was inundated with
more than 100 made of Awesome
nerdfighters for an evening of hilarity
fun and me epically failing at reading
in Dutch today
poor trick the bank for each like that
Hey look
the way Heinkels wooden shoes with Willy
he's a pirate when I say bitter you say
balls bitter I mean Hank people were
singing a song you wrote in a bar in
Amsterdam allow me to quote David after
his visit to the dentist I feel funny is
this real-life oh and Hank one other
story I was being interviewed by a
journalist in Holland and she said she'd
read Paper Towns in both English and
Dutch and then she said it was much
better in Dutch and then I was like why
and she said much funnier
so nerdfighters that you can read in
Dutch you should definitely buy Paper
Towns in Dutch that way my publisher
Lemna Scott will bring me back over to
Holland and I can even more bitterballen
and more Hawking shocking and I will
live happily ever after
okay Hank they're a bunch of awesome
links Amsterdam me and otherwise in the
sidebar I will talk to you about the
peep seating situation on Tuesday and
now I have to go sleep dftba